[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Releasing your
new app on Google Play
means you're likely to have
gone through many checks
like testing for quality and
making sure bugs are fixed.
It's also important to make
sure you check your app
for potential policy issues.
Here are 10 ways to stay on
the right side of Google Play
policy.
Review our Policy Center.
The Developer Policy Center
found at play.google.com/policy
is your resource for everything
related to Google Play policy.
We've organized the
policies into themes
represented by tiles.
You can select a specific
policy to learn more about it
and see visual examples
of common violations.
Describe your app appropriately.
Taking the time to
describe your app
can save you from receiving
a metadata policy violation.
Read through your short
and full descriptions
and remove any excessive keyword
lists, irrelevant information,
or user testimonials.
Your app description should
be appropriate for all ages.
Remember that every translation
of your app description
needs to be compliant
with the metadata policy.
Used images you
have the rights to.
If you want to stay on the right
side of intellectual property
policy, it's best to create
your own images and videos
to promote your app.
Your app icon, feature graphic,
and any other assets you upload
to your Store
listing should only
include images you
have the right to use.
If you've been
granted permission
to use assets owned
by others, you
can notify the App Review
team using this form.
And just like your
app description,
the images and videos
in your Store listing
should be appropriate
for all ages.
Rate your app accurately.
Once you've completed the
content rating questionnaire,
you're almost ready
to submit your app.
It's important to provide
accurate responses in order
to receive an accurate
rating as apps that
aren't rated correctly
or aren't rated at all
can be removed from
the Play Store.
Handle user data with care.
Is your app
collecting user data?
User data can include
information provided
by users, about users, or
about their interactions
with the app or device.
If you're collecting
user data, you
need to include a privacy
policy in your Store listing
and in your app.
The privacy policy
should let users
know what data you're collecting
and why you're collecting it.
Read over the Personal
and Sensitive Information
section under our
User Data Policy
to see what types of data
to pay special attention to.
Make sure the ads in your
app are policy compliant.
When you submit
your app for review,
the Google Play
team also reviews
the content and behavior
of the ads within your app.
Make sure the ad content doesn't
include adult images, violence,
or anything else that would
violate our content policy.
Ad behavior should
be straightforward.
We don't allow ads that are
disruptive or deceptive,
including ads that pose
as system notifications,
ads that aren't dismissible,
or ads that appear
after a user closes the app.
A policy issue with your ads
can lead to an app rejection
or suspension.
Check with your ad provider to
learn about filtering options.
Don't forget the
restricted content policy.
Review your app and
your Store listing
page for any
restrictive content,
such as adult content,
violence, or drugs.
If you're concerned about
any of your content,
read through the
Restricted Content Policy
for more details and examples.
Any apps that contain or
feature user-generated content
must take additional
precautions in order
to provide a policy
compliant app experience.
If this describes
your app, check out
the User-Generated Content
Policy to learn more.
Update your email preferences.
You're almost ready to submit.
Just one final
thing-- take a second
to update your email address
on the Account Details
page in your developer console.
If a policy issue
does come up, we
can contact you with the
necessary steps to address it.
Congratulations.
Now it's time to push that
shiny, blue Publish button.
Fix any policy issues
found in review.
Even though you've checked
your app against our policies,
it's always possible that your
app gets rejected or suspended
after review.
If your app or app
update gets rejected,
keep in mind that many
violations can be fixed.
Just follow the steps in the
notification from Google Play
email you received
to address the issue
and submit your app again.
Reach out to us for support.
If you disagree with
a policy violation
or if you'd like help
resolving your policy issue,
you can contact our
Policy Support team.
Simply use the contact details
in the notification email
or click on the question mark
at the bottom of each page
in the Policy Center.
For the quickest response, make
sure to include your package
name.
For more information
on Google Play policy,
head over to the
Developer Policy Center.
If you want more tips on how
to launch your app or game
business, check out the
other videos in this series
and download the Playbook for
Developers app on Google Play.